hey everybody it's Mike from order flows
and welcome back to my channel you know
in today's video I'll be talking about
stopping volume sort of just to follow
up on the video that I did on stopping
volume um the other day because there
was a couple questions about it so again
you know if you're enjoying my videos
and you're learning from them be sure to
subscribe to the channel so you don't
miss any new uploads
and again you know feel free to leave
your comments in the section comment
section below you know maybe uh you know
what you've learned from this video you
know how you find my videos helpful and
more importantly you know if there's any
topics you'd like me to discuss in the
future as well uh please uh comment
about it now what I'm going to be using
today is the go charting platform
um you know we recently got our order
flow indicators added to go charting and
you know one of the indicators that's
very important to my own trading is the
order flows ratios now there's two
ratios there's a ratio bonds High ratio
bounds low and ratio bonds High
indicates price exhaustion ratio bounds
low indicates stopping volume or Price
defense and really all the ratio is it's
just the order flow right it's just
calculating
um a ratio on the order flow and what
we've found in our analysis you know
again I used to do these calculations in
my head years ago before I even had any
um you know my own software coming out
you know this is one of the big
additions to it when I when I launched
the order of Illustrator years ago and I
would always look for areas where there
would be heavy volume coming in near the
high of a bar right because why is that
important well that's important because
that to me is volume that can
potentially stop a move so if we're at a
high and I see Heavy volume coming in I
know there's Supply coming into the
market and if there's Supply coming into
the market that can potentially stop a
move from going higher just as if there
was
um strong bids coming in on a move to
the downside that would potentially stop
a move from going lower okay and
how to use the ratios to see that is
it's you're looking for a number between
basically 0.7 and 0 so you can see right
here on the euro currency now this is a
euro currency this is a five minute
chart this is just this morning
um we came all the way up here to uh
106.46 and I can see there's heavy
volume coming in up here I can see I got
the bearish ratio coming in
um all right it's coming in at uh as as
0.11 it's red now the difference between
the go charting platform and the Ninja
Trader platform
with order flows is on gold charting it
will only print
the ratio if it's within the threshold
okay if it's if it's
um a ratio bounds high or a ratio bounds
low that's why you don't see on go
charting numbers above and below each
bar
but you see them only on go charting if
it has you know one that meets the
threshold so you can see here the 0.11
that's why you don't see any number up
here here or here in these red candles
because they don't meet the threshold
you see you know here 0.61 more stopping
volume so let's just sort of take it
back a little bit okay so the market had
been going up and I see a 0.11 I see a
bearish ratio bounds low how do I know
it's a ratio bounds low is because it's
between
um
0.7 and
0.01 okay if it was say 146
0.2 then I know it's a ratio Bond's High
because that's above 30. and
a ratio balance low again means price
defense stopping volume but again
where do you want to see stopping volume
you want to see stopping volume
after a move okay because here people
say well isn't this stopping volume 0.69
well
it's not making a move right there's no
move to stop here if anything maybe it's
acting as support but the whole point of
stopping volume is to stop a move that
tends to term stop right volume right
it's volume that's coming in to stop a
move so you're going to be looking for
them coming in at swing highs to stop
moves up or at swing lows to stop moves
down
okay in this case you know again we had
gone up up up up
now they're stopping volume coming in we
come up here we do make a new high by
what one tick here okay then on the move
down you're starting to see Supply also
come in here with the 0.61 I mean this
one it's nice to see this Supply coming
in here with the 0.61 but up here it's
very obvious right and then you see the
point of control right up here at the
top
this bar it's just sort of poked up here
you even left the tail that's what this
little box is around here around these
two zeros but um
really the whole point of
stopping volume is to stop a move from
going
higher or lower
okay so again it's not that you just see
one anywhere and it's looking to you
know take a trade
you want to find them at swing highs and
swing lows and again stopping volume
it's not a standalone indicator in the
sense of it's going to say stopping
volume it's a ratio okay and what it
means when the ratio is between 0.7 and
0.01
it indicates a ratio bound is low which
is stopping volume right here right you
want a move to stop
now let's take a look at another example
okay so this is e-mini's yesterday okay
and here is a 0.65 right point of
control on the bottom of the bar I know
that there's some decent volume I could
just see here again this is e-mini five
minute chart I can see it 1.2 K 1.2 000
contracts traded on the bid here even
892 on the offer I could see Heavy
volume coming in here now is this
stopping volume well that's what I
talked about when talking about where
are we this is an area that we have been
trading this is at 130 okay since
basically 11 45 more or less you know we
had been trading around that area so
it's not really a move that you're
looking for the market to stop I mean if
anything maybe it's supportive buying
but you know really if I was looking at
this as being stopping volume instead of
being coming in here at 65 and a quarter
you know maybe the market was trading in
here and then dipped down to you know 60
and then rallied back up okay so
you know even though I have this
um bullish Prominent Point of control a
lot of things going on in this bar okay
you know if I'm going to say it's
stopping volume I want to see what's
going to happen if we break through that
right and we break through and we sell
down now there is some volume coming in
here again the the next time we trade
down here 1.9 K 1.8 K even
754 contracts trade just below it
but again it's just one of those things
where it's not necessarily stopping
volume when it's coming in an area of
sideways activity right if you're
looking for Price exhaustion right same
thing if you're looking for Price
exhaustion you want to move to have
happened you want prices and Traders to
be exhausted just as if they're stopping
volume you want a move
to happen and Traders step in and say
you know what we're not going to let
this price go any lower or any higher
and defend it
all right so just to wrap it all up
it's you know people they get attracted
to order flow because they think it's
going to give them every single turn in
the market it's not you know markets
don't exist for people to read the order
flow and trade it or read price action
and trade it they exist for a purpose
right for
um
people to transfer risk you know Farmers
or whoever to another party and get paid
in a sense now
with the order flow right most of the
time you see the order flow it's just
normal Market activity okay but that's
where the tools of the order flows
Trader come in to point out certain
things to you that hey you know what
maybe they're a stopping volume here
right maybe there's price exhaustion
here or you know maybe there's volume
that matters coming in at a certain
level all sort of things like that right
because it's it's one of those things
it's like watching soccer soccer is a
very boring game to watch for the most
part right 90 minutes
um you know just kids kicking balls
around okay but it's just that
moment of Brilliance right and it lasts
maybe 30 45 seconds you know pass pass
pass
that is just so beautiful The Watcher
than a goal is scored and the market is
the same thing right it's
a lot of boring activity and then you
just see that moment something flashes
on your screen where somebody just gave
it away you know gave away their their
intention of what they're doing in the
market and then the market makes that
move so
I'm going to wrap up this video again
this is on the go charting platform
my order flow Trader indicators are
available on there
and you know what if you're interested I
did create a trading course based on the
go charting platform I'll put the link
in the description below
so thanks for watching this everyone and
I'll catch you guys on the next video
bye bye
thank you